they said his tweets were harmful now
they want them by the armful and was
babbling Joe unaware he's not the first
senator from Delaware politico's White
House bureau chief Jonathan Lemire yes
that Jonathan Lemire
White House officials want Trump
uh back on Twitter because he'll scare
voters away from Republicans this
despite polls showing the GOP gaining
voters from traditional Democrat groups
like Hispanics blacks and dead people
Lemire said this during a show named
after a German sex act the other thing
White House officials are cheering for
a number of them told me this over the
weekend that if Elon Musk indeed takes
Twitter they hope the first thing he
does is put Donald Trump back on it they
think that if training starts tweeting
again it'll just simply remind these
voters of the crazy that accompanied his
time in office particularly around
January 6th he'll amplify these Fringe
messages he'll amplify these friends
right-wing candidates and that can only
be good for Democrats they think well
that'll work reminding voters how crazy
things were back when we weren't on the
verge of World War III and when a gallon
of gas costs two bucks and a loaf of
bread didn't cost as much as a BMW
but it's true Joe needs help he puts the
assist in Assisted Living
yesterday he said this
and there have not been many senators
from Delaware it's a small state
manufacturer's never been won
[Laughter]
I know I know I know
uh actually uh you were a senator
from Delaware
I'll get to get both of those wrong for
36 damn years God I wish I was that
divorced from reality
he should share what he's taking with
the rest of America because we've earned
it
but at least he's not being outshined by
his VP according to two New York Times
reporters took two of them Kamala Harris
has felt disrespected by West Wing staff
because they don't stand when she enters
a room
apparently it's the only incompetence
the Biden Administration won't stand for
let's go to the view she's feeling
disrespected because she's seen staffers
In The West Wing when she walks into the
room who we're not standing for her and
they always stand for president abidings
people it would behoove everyone to
maybe have a giant meeting and say let's
go over how this actually works so that
everybody's clear because we know that
everybody has little micro aggressions
that they may not be aware that they're
putting out there so let's have this big
meeting and if I see you do it again
you're out
clutch use of the word behoove by Whoopi
especially since your co-hosts actually
have hooves
take it personally people stand when
Biden enters the room to block him from
walking out through a window
what say you Joe hey look look have some
respect all right when a lady enters the
room you stand up all right that's the
way it is whether it's the first lady of
the United States Kamala Harris or the
vice president Jill W bush I mean you do
what's right man look I'm old school I
want to go back to the old ways let that
guy have Twitter and he can do his thing
and I'll go into the basement and I'll
do what I do best you know say things
like Charlottesville January 6th all
that stuff look I'm from Delaware man
I'm the first guy from Delaware to ever
do anything that I'm aware of Delaware
I'm aware of Delaware
and anyone who says otherwise I'll do
push-ups on your grades
Iris I have to say that two-headed
nerdfest on The View might have a point
they need Trump to be a distraction from
their disastrous Administration and
Trump's tweets they're going to do that
because like as much as I love Trump's
tweets we understand his accomplishments
when he's not tweeting well I I
I feel like they've never watched a a
bad guy movie ever the entire
Administration just so you're gonna
invest more in trying to camouflage your
bad Deeds than actually fix them it's
like the plot to keep him from becoming
King if they just would have left Arthur
alone he would have died the first night
he was out from the castle but no they
go through this elaborate scheme and
these planning and all these meetings to
get trumped back because once he's back
they'll forget about inflation they'll
forget about all these issues in this
country in crime rate because they're
going to be so angry that he's back and
then there's the one guy who's like well
we could just fix some of our policies
and get get that son of a [ __ ] out of
here he doesn't get it no no stick to
the plan it's like Dr Evil like they
just don't they don't get it so and
they're saying it out loud yeah which is
even worse at least Republicans we do
our bidding behind and then it shows up
with a great reveal they're like hey
we're gonna put Trump back on Twitter so
you guys won't pay attention to what
we're doing
[Laughter]
cat
uh you could talk about Trump's tweets
or you could talk about how that what do
you think of uh uh the views advice for
Kamala it's not advice for Kamala it's
advice for everyone else yeah they're
all clearly the problem with Kamala
doing nothing it's like yeah that's the
meeting they need
I I I just don't I mean I don't even
know if she would appreciate that though
because
starting from even before she was a vice
president her campaign her you know her
selection as the vice president
she likes to have the excuse of the only
reason people don't like me is because
they are racist or they are sexist not
because I have this important job
especially when you look at you know the
president
um and that's there it's their fault
that I haven't gotten anything done and
that I'm not competent and I just go
Trot around giggling
but if they had that meeting then maybe
she wouldn't be able to claim that yeah
I think she's plus then she'd have to go
to a meeting she doesn't want to go to a
meeting she doesn't say yeah if I were I
wouldn't go to that meeting Joey and I'm
not her you're not her no you've
accomplished something in your life yes
yes um listen you want people to stand
up when you walk into a room give them
something to stand for go to the border
and bring back a solution go to Europe
and remember what freaking country
you're in right you know what do one
press briefing where you have a prepared
answer for the questions they're about
to ask you that everyone else knows
they're about to ask you and and like
Whoopi Goldberg those are not
microaggressions those are just
aggressions they don't like her because
they because she makes them look bad
another name for a show Mike Rowe
aggressions
what am I doing here I should be behind
the scenes coming up with these ideas
Emily hey man that was last night I'm
here tonight can we can we just keep you
are you are Emily Joe you're our very
own Joey Jones there we go very um sorry
Peter Ducey I'm so tired of hearing him
our very own peter Ducey it's not like
he lives in my house Emily although I
feel like I say that sometimes yeah you
do say it and I'm tired of it I want you
to stop all right last word make it a
good one okay well just on that note I
think this is something that has been
the Hallmark of Kamala Harris's entire
career which is that all she has been
seeking is the position itself without
having to earn it right with every every
position she held rising up through the
ranks of California and then the senator
and the now Vice President it was only
about occupying that seat having nothing
to do with earning and earning the
Goodwill and that's why in the Bay Area
which she perceives as her home where
she's from She's the lowest approval
rate actually in the country 38 approval
wait what does that tell you when the
voters who know you best like you the
least right so when she she deems as a
microaggression or Whoopi says it's a
microaggression when no one stands when
you walk in it might just be plain old
lack of any respect for you because
you've done nothing as you've pointed
out and it reminds me as well of that
Vogue cover she was on the cover of
Vogue and remember she had a conniption
fit afterward with Anna Wintour she said
you put me in speaker in sneakers but
Anna Wintour the editor said it's
because we wanted you to be relatable we
loved that that you were here
representing all of these millions of
Americans she said that could relate to
you isn't this a good thing but no
Kamala Harris wanted to be separate she
wanted to be elite because it's all
about just the position and my sort of
like royalty analogy is similar to yours
is to that it's just like in Gladiator
when Joaquin Phoenix was all about
having that one position so we stabbed
the hot guy in the side oh I hated that
Russell Crow oh yeah like at his Peak
listen we can fix this right now you
guys want to like Kamala Harris it's
real easy yes bongos
yeah I forgot about the Bongo you play
some Bongos all of a sudden their stuff
doesn't sound so anymore yeah
all right up next Liberals are shoving
it in your face hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else